this is a production of Cornell
University
so good morning everybody I'd like to
welcome you with Simon Joe's thesis talk
to assignment is presenting his talk
today but he won't actually have his
defense till December sometime this
summer I think the faculty voted to have
imminently graduating students do their
talks in the seminar series and so Simon
is the test case for this and we seem to
has gotten a very good turnout so thank
you all for coming
Simon came to us from Shenzhen by the
University of Washington in Seattle and
is a PhD student plant biology
department he however has more of an
ecological background and like many
ecology students he wanted to work on a
project that has absolutely nothing to
do with this thesis advisors research
and that also meant then that Simon's
thesis has been almost entirely self
funded through ta ships and grants that
he's written which is also typical
ecology students and specifically Simon
came to me wanting to work on pathogens
on roots which is not something I have a
lot of experience with so I learned a
lot from Simon and that respect
and Simon has also really pioneered new
research methods in my lab specifically
metabolomics and quantitative genetics
or genome-wide Association studies and
more importantly has been very creative
in combining those two research methods
and doing quantitative genetics of
large-scale metabolomics and really
doing very nice analysis of large
datasets and then applying that as you
see here from this picture and now
somewhat shortened title to looking at
his areum Mays interactions cos areum
infection of routes with that Simon
thank you thank you everyone for showing
up today and I just want to make sure
everybody hear me all right good good
okay so we can start all right so thank
you George for the surprisingly kind
introduction so I guess I have to I have
to revise my acknowledged section now
that's maybe a little bit too mean
worded but I was think about that well
I'm giving the talk so today I'm going
to tell you about what I've been doing
for the past three and a half years
which looking at trying to identify
cellular and physiological regulation of
May's biochemical defense against
Fusarium cremini era so as George
mentioned when I first joined George
slab I really had no idea a very vague
idea about what I wanted to do so only
as I know is I want to work on brute
microbe interaction which George doesn't
really do any of that so I went to
George and I say I want to do this and
this and that and George said okay the
only possible way you can get some money
from me is if you work on corn
so that really narrowed down the things
I can do here which is corn root disease
which I know absolutely nothing about at
the time so I started from Wikipedia
which surprisingly there's the whole
page of giving all the maze diseases
that are possibly out there and that's
how I find out about Fusarium Grameen
erm so if you serum Grameen Ihram is a
destructive and widespread fungal
pathogen that in fact maze depending on
the tissue type at developmental stages
of that interaction you can get sidling
blight stock rot or ear rot image and
every year this three disease is caused
by the same passage and collectively
give you hundreds of millions of your
loss
so in corn so this is a pretty
economically relevant passage and to
work with so when we first started to
work on this pathogen we really want to
just have some kind of symptom or
phenotype to work with so in a through
artificial inoculation experiment we see
that Fusarium can induce significant
reduction in the total root grows in the
seedlings so this can be quantified by
taking a 2d picture like this and then
use a computer algorithm that is
developed in Leon coaching's lab we can
actually quantify that and compare and
show that this is statistically
significant and this phenotype actually
is complete it's repeatable and
consistent enough such that we can use
it to screen a natural diversity panel
and see if there's any natural variation
in this fungus induced morphological
change and indeed when we do that across
a diversity panel we see that v73 which
is the reference mates genotype where
we've initially started with turn out to
be one of the more susceptible genotypes
with its total root growth being reduced
by over 50% after
eriell inoculation whereas we also see
their four genotypes that does not show
any significant reduction in their total
root grows after Fusarium after Fusarium
inoculation and they turn out to be our
candidate resistant genotypes so for my
work i've been focusing on this genotype
mow 17 because it has the most available
genetic resources out there and i will
come back to that later to explain what
i mean by that so before we go any
further we really want to confirm that
the symptom that we observe actually
tell us something about resistance level
so we did that by measuring for example
fungal gene expression mycotoxin
production as well as visual symptoms
scoring and by all three matrices
consistently we see that most of enchain
turned out to be more resistant than b73
against this area so then we can
actually ask the question why what's the
genetic and physiological mechanism
behind this contrasting resistance level
between these two genotypes so we're
answering these questions taking a
quantitative genetics approach so for
those of you with less background in
that so we there are genetic populations
that's produced by crossing B 73 and Moe
17 are susceptible and resistant
genotype and then produce what we call a
recombinant inbred line populations with
shuffled genomes between the true
parents and what we can do then is to
measure some kind of quantitative
phenotype so that we can statistically
associate this phenotype with a
particular locus or low-side within the
genome okay so then the question really
come down to what kind of trait what
kind of quantitative trait do we really
want to measure so since we're working
with plan disease supposingly
what we really want to measure what
actually matter is the disease symptoms
severity in the field okay how does that
impact your yield how does that impact
your crops so it does come with a lot of
advantage of doing that so for example
as much the results from such a study
will be much easier to translate your
application you tend to identify the
low-side was the most major effect you
capture environmental influences and the
technique for phenotyping is usually
simple however on the flip
I love this we can also try to quantify
some kind of biochemical or molecular
markers in the lab and the advantage of
doing that will be you kind of get some
idea about what's the mechanism behind
the resistance you get and the genetic
architecture of this kind of trace are
usually much more simple and then you
can very importantly you get very
consistent and accurate quantification
which are hard to achieve under field
conditions for disease severity and
perhaps more important for graduate
students it's much less work to do okay
so if we forget about the less work and
simple technique just say we really want
to do it right which kind of phenotype
are we going to are we going to choose
for our particular passel system so if
we come back to see the link blight
disease caused by Fusarium specifically
we see that consistent scoring of
disease symptom severity is very hard
either in either in field conditions or
even in lab you know the symptoms are in
the root so you what are you going to
measure and secondly if we come back to
the to the historical statistics we see
that the settling fly severity where is
widely from year to year and by the way
this is when I started working on this
disease and since then there's been a
linear decrease in disease severity so
somehow I feel like I should take credit
for that
okay but what the point I'm trying to
make here is that the environmental
impact seems to be really large for
disease severity and finally there has
been work done with Sierra and Mayes
interaction but this is done in years
but what's been shown is that the gene
genetic architecture for this
interaction is very complex many genetic
loci seem to contribute to the disease
resistance or to disease severity
phenotype so taken all three factors
together we decide to measure
biochemical markers under laboratory
conditions
rather than doing any kind of disease
severity scoring so what we decided to
do this is to take seedling root samples
of p73 and mow 17 recombinant inbred
lines we take those samples subject them
to lcms analysis of metabolites as well
as a new technology developed by carl
kremlin here in at buckler's lab looking
using a 3 prime RNA see technology to
look at their transcriptome and if we
combine the metabolomic data with the
quantitative genetics setup we can do
some kind of metabolite QTL mapping and
if we combine the 2 omics data set we
can start to do cross omics network and
system analysis so most of the work I'm
going to present today will come out of
these two analysis here combining the
three measures here okay so the first
story I want to tell you from this study
is looking at looking at just comparing
B 73 and mo 17 are two parental
genotypes will soar without fungus
inoculation what I'm showing here are
cloud plots and each bubble here
represent a single mass feature that the
mass spec machine can detect and in
green I'm showing the the metabolize or
the mass features that are significantly
up regulated by Fusarium induction in
red are significantly reduced but really
the take-home message is that a lot of
bubbles in b73 not so many bubbles in mo
17 and what that tells you is that B 73
the susceptible genotype seems to be
significantly responding metabolically
speaking to Fusarium inoculation whereas
there's not so much going on in mo 17 in
terms of its metabolic an do then is we
can compare the constitutively tableau
of the susceptible B 73 and a resistant
mo 17 and ask what are the difference
there because the differential
metabolize will likely be related to
resistance against Fusarium and not so
surprisingly we find a lot because
they're over 700 masked features that
are significantly different which is
still a lot to work with like which one
should we actually look at them so I did
a second comparison looking at fungus
induction in B 73 and from there we
found over 300 metabolites or mass
features that are significantly
different and if we look for the overlap
between this two which means this
metabolize are both constitutively
different between my susceptible and
resistant genotype as well as being
responsive to fungus inoculation those
will be my high priority pool so I found
less than 100 mask features there and if
I filter out the ones
have low intensity that's harder to work
with and then we find about 30 mask
features so among the 30 mask features
there are some known metabolize with
bioactive bio activities against
Fusarium which will be good positive
control for us to show that this
approach is actually effective but what
we're actually more interesting are the
unknowns here so what are the unknowns
two of the unknowns that really capture
my eyes are just two masks features
shown by their negative mass-to-charge
ratio here and retention time so from
now I'm just refer to them to refer to
them as a 19 and 777 and you see that in
both p7 history and MO 17 they are
inducible by fungus inoculation and
their constitutively different between
our two genotypes and what's really
interesting to me that okay is that the
structure seems to be related to each
other and QT Jung in Franco there's lab
help me to field a purify there's two
compounds and perform 2d NMR on them to
clarify their structures here so we have
a sucrose backbone right here connected
to them one Furillo Cassatt to Furillo
Cassatt and then different nacido groups
and really the only difference between
this to metabolize is this one
additional estilo group here on the two
position okay so this metabolize have
previously been reported in medicinal
plants such as smilax in this case my
lips china and that's why they have to
they goes by the name such as Smuggler's
I see a smile aside a so those are names
given by the natural chemist and okay so
they're finally in this kind of plant
and to me they're really there to heart
because I kind of grow up eating it in
China you can make you can make this
dark jello like saying from smilax and
supposingly will be rien reached is in
this middle side as - like compound and
you can just have it as a dessert okay
so that's cool then we really if they're
related to resistance against truce area
and we want to show is there any in
vitro final activity against this area
and that's where it's really interesting
when we did
virtual liquid culture si we see that
the try assimilated Nikolas I see does
not show any significant activity
against Fusarium where is the bias in
latest Melissa a show you a significant
growth of inhibition and notice that the
concentration of smiles side a is
actually lower than smoogle as I see
because this is reflecting there in vivo
in vivo concentration so even at low
concentration the dye assimilated - at a
seems to be more bioactive than the
triassic the latest Nikolas I see ok so
then we can ask the question why are
they why is there natural variation
between for this two compounds in our
population so we measure this two
compounds across the recombinant inbred
lines which can help us to identify the
genetic loci that is controlling or
associated with this - was this -
metabolite and perhaps not so
surprisingly we see a co localized
quantitative trait locus or QTL at the
beginning of chromosomes 3 so if we if
we sub set to become the umbrella in
population by different alleles at this
locus we see that for the ones that
carry the p73 allele that preferentially
accumulates nicholas i see just like v73
the parental line whereas has less of
the smile si a so that's pretty good
segregation and then we want to confirm
the mapping result from becoming inbred
lines using a different genetic
population called near isogenic lines
also generated from p73 and most 17 and
indeed we find that when we have P 73
and most of a team here the phenotype
I'm measuring is the ratio of this tree
metabolites in be 73 we have a lot of
simple as I see and not so much smiles
at a so we have a very low bar whereas
in most Seventeen's the other way around
and when we look at the near as organic
lines
some of them looks just like be
semi-sweet and the latter here annual
taste what's the genetic background so
even though for example this two lines
the genetic background is most 17 it
does have a b7 III like phenotype and we
have example from from the other side
whereas when you have even if you have a
seventy-three genetic background their
phenotype looks just like moe 17 when we
do a PETA when we do a tea pass between
them we see that there is indeed a
significant difference between this
difference are near as a genetic lines
and then on top I'm showing the genetic
map associated with all this nearest
Jenny flies wears in red I'm showing the
piece of history allele in blue I'm
showing the most 17 allele so if you
look at the correspondence between the
phenotype and genotype we can actually
further narrow down our QTL area to less
than 600 Kb
so this particular area would contain a
gene that we think is causing the
difference in sniffles I see as smart as
I a constitutive abundance so remember
these two compounds are only different
by one acetyl group so when we're
looking at this cutie our result was
that okay that's pretty straightforward
we're looking for a pseudo transferase
that's going to add a student group to
that tooth - I ate and of course when
you look at there there's no solute
transfer rates there so for that part as
so at that time this whole project was
kind of dead in water we don't have a
candidate gene we have a small genetic
area but we really don't know you know
there's probably a dozen genes in there
we really don't know which one we should
look at so that's when I was taking a
vacation and physically my wife last
December okay and I was really bored in
her office and I have nothing to do so I
decided to play with some of this data I
thought that was hopeless at the time so
I decided to plot out all the most 17b
said ministry and their recombinant
inbred lines based on their constitutive
concentration of these two compounds so
that's when I noticed something rather
weird so we know all all alone that most
seventeen has a lot of smile as I a not
so much sniffles I see and we know the
opposite is true for be semi-sweet so
for all this time I've been assuming
that all the recumbent in bread lines
should be distributed kind of in a
negatively correlated way right because
if we assume that or if we hypothesize
that there is a difference in the co
transfer race then you should have
either a lot of the substrate or a lot
of the product so then you'll have a
negative correlation but that's not the
case here if you see that you see a
clear positive correlation trend
actually more than that
there's
be two separate classes one being more
like mo 17 the other be more like b73
okay so I was like if only there's one
way I can draw a line here and separate
them and that's when the advantage of
marrying us statistician become really
really great okay so just so basically
my wife said oh you just meet neither
linear discrimination analysis to be
done here I was like let's do that
whatever that is okay
that's exactly what she did for me and
we show that we can actually separate
the recombinant inbred lines into the
most a machine like ones versus the b73
like ones so we can separate this this
population based on their phenotypes so
we have two phenotypic classes and if we
say that there's some kind of genes
that's causing this discrimination then
the expression expression of that gene
should be significantly different
between my true phenotypic classes so
that's exactly what I did when I
compared the gene expression data
between this fingertip to fingertip
classes across an entire genome so here
I'm showing the negative log of P value
based on students t-test and we see that
the genes that are most significantly
differentially expressed between this
two phenotypic class indeed locate right
within my QTL area if i zoom into like
this QTL area the gene that's most
differentially expressed there's a
saline insensitive to which is a saline
receptor that's positively regulating a
saline signaling so if we look at the
segregation within the population we see
that the recombinant inbred lines that
have a phenotype that just looked like a
73 tend to express iron to a much high
significantly higher level so this was
lead us to the hypothesis that su
expression and hence a saline signaling
is a positive regulator of smaller size
a two single size C transition okay so
and we can test that hypothesis ideally
by looking at iron two mutant but that's
not available in maize so we did the
next best thing we can do which is
looking at a saline bio synthetic mutant
which constitutively make
so when we compare b73 it's well typed
in the background and ACS to six mutants
which produce less a saline indeed we
see that there's less Smith Nicholas I
see as smile si a being produced
constitutively and what's even more
exciting is that we can actually rescue
this phenotype by exogenously adding a
saline back to the ceilings and in
well-typed background you can actually
induce these two compounds with
exogenously so with this experiment we
have demonstrated that two novel
compounds found in maize Smiggle aside a
as Nicolas IC and smile si a that are
related to Fusarium resistance are
positively regulated by a saline
signaling in vivo so that's the first
story so far how does this fit in with
the literature about ethylene and
Fusarium so embody and wheat it has been
shown that absolutely actually
contribute to the susceptibility of this
area so in this case for example if you
treat Harley Leafs with ethylene you'd
be a stronger symptom and more fungal
commedia whereas in wheat if you have a
transgenic line that produced less
ethylene then you have a less severe
phenotype okay so this fit in with our
result really well because we show that
ethylene promotes melosa a which is the
bio active compound transition into
simple as IC which is the deactivated
form so it looks like a this nicolas i
see as smile as i a provides some kind
of biochemical link between a saline
signaling and Fusarium resistance okay
so so far we've looked at two particular
metabolites that is significantly
different between the true genotypes
okay what we cannot do unfortunately is
to tell you how much this two
metabolites actually contribute to
resistance quantitatively because we
only found ethylene as an important
factor we cannot specifically manipulate
these two compounds in vivo so really if
you look back we found over seven
hundred metabolites where mask features
that are significantly different between
the two genotype and
one of those could give you a
disproportional impact on Fusarium
resistance and there's really no reason
I'm telling you compound that I just
tell you it's much more significant than
every other every other thing in this
700 poles okay but what I did show you
is that we can do QTL mapping with mass
features and that does give a lead us to
somewhere in terms of the genetic
control so if we can do gin QTL mapping
for two mass features there's really
nothing to stop us from doing it for all
700 mass features so the only thing is
that instead of showing you lost or for
two metabolites I'm going to show you
the distribution of QTL for all this 700
mapping that I did so in result on this
plot every on x-axis I'm laying out the
genetic locus on the earth in their
chromosomal order and on y-axis instead
of looking at how strongly that
particular locus is associated with one
particular metabolite instead I'm
measuring how many metabolites that give
you a significant UTL at that particular
locus okay so immediately we recognize
this tower in being 2.9 towards the end
of chromosome 2 okay and this is really
interesting because being 2.09 has been
previously associated with multiple
disease resistance before in maize so
then our question is what's happening in
here what are the genes that is giving
that's affecting all this metabolize
because collectively they affect over 17
which have seven TMS features that's
about 10% of what's different between
these two genotypes together okay and is
there only one gene in there that's
affecting all this metabolites
simultaneously or are there just
multiple genes that's in the short
genetic interval kind of clustering
together okay and this is when you
translate that into physical distance we
still have about eight megabase to cover
and hundreds of genes in there so again
we can possibly come up with any rep
candidate genes just by looking at this
plot so what we did there then is we can
get to the QTL by doing the table QTL
mapping but when we can also look at the
x
oppression of genes and then ask the
question how is gene expression
correlated with our metabolite abundance
across this recombinant inbred line
population and our hypothesis is that if
there's only one gene in there then that
one gene should be significantly
correlated with all the mass features
that map to this locus whereas if there
are multiple genes in the interval each
regulating a subset then only the subset
and their regulator gene should be
correlated with each other so what's the
result that we got from that in this
crate in this case I'm laying out all
the transcript across a chromosome of
maize and then on the y-axis I'm
measuring the median Pearson's
correlation coefficient off that 75 mass
feature with each transcript and again
we start to see this very clean signal
within our QTL region in being 3.09 if
we zoom in there and ask for each
transcript what's the number of mass
features that has that particular
transcript as the most single most
correlated transcript we see that we
have a clear winner in a putative
vesicular transport protein which would
suggest that this single protein is
regulating many metabolites
simultaneously so to actually prove that
help us or them support that hypothesis
we found two independent mutation
insertion lines that has this particular
gene knocked out and when we can confirm
the insertion we see that there's a
trend of decrease in this very important
metabolite defense metabolite cut in
bowler glucoside so at this point I have
no statistics to support my claim
because this is based on very small
sample size but we're in the process of
poking of the seeds so that hopefully
soon we'll add a steric scare so this
will show us that indeed the vesicular
transport protein is important - it's
important for the metabolism of defense
metabolites such as tambour glucoside
but that's kind of unexpected how could
a vesicular transport protein related to
a secondary metabolism so one way we
look at it is how about
synthetic pathway off Bendix annoyed
with off which Timbo a glucoside is a
member of so we see that because without
a glucoside
die boa in boa all this men's oxy no is
a highly cytotoxic so for plant cells
actually makes sense for them to be kept
in the vacuole in my and the microsomes
so we think that the G that biosynthetic
genes should also localized in this
cellular compartment which are made from
vesicles so if there is some kind of a
disruption in the vesicular transport
protein or in that particular trend but
with secure transport protein then there
might be something there might be
something disrupting this entire bio
synthetic pathway as well ok so so far
I've been done all the studies within
the realm of IBA uh b73 mo seventeen
recombinant inbred lines I've shown you
we can do mapping with two metabolites
or we can do mapping across the entire
metabolome however there are limited
genetic diversity looking at this
recombinant inbred lines as I've shown
you there are only 700 over slightly
over 700 mass features that we can map
with this population but what I hope
I've convinced you is that this
experimental approach of combining
metabolomics transcriptomics and
quantitative genetics it's really
powerful when it comes to dissecting the
secondary metabolism so we decided to
take this approach extend it to a much
more chemically diverse genetic
genome-wide Association study panel
which include over 280 genotypes and
from there we found more than 3,900 Mass
features that we can dissect using the
exact same approach okay
so we're lucky that the same diversity
panel the transcriptome has previously
has only recently been analyzed by Carl
Kremlin here in at buckler's group so we
use the exact same tissue type and we
try to keep the growth condition as
consistent as possible looking at this
will be the emergence certainly if
looking at the tip of that and the base
of it okay so we harvest the tip and
and base of all this over 280 lines and
then perform some performative element
analysis so the first thing before we
even go into the genetics is we try to
parse out the vast data set that we have
how can we explain the variance in this
pretty big data set so the first thing
we see that is the first thing we see is
that the tissue type seems to be really
important not so surprisingly so the
base and tip seems to clustering very
well with each other so that means we
should probably analyze those data sets
separately from each other
another way to visualize this is that if
we can do two-way anova on every single
mouse feature and say how are they
different either by tissue or by genetic
sub population or interactive and we see
the vast majority of them are
significantly different based on tissue
type whereas by genetically defined
defined subpopulations less of them are
actually significantly different okay so
when it comes to metabolomics are always
bothering question is you know what are
the metabolites so people always act as
but this is great so but but what are
the metabolites unfortunately not like
in transcriptomics you can map to the
genome and say okay this is this gene
and this is that gene you can't really
say that with metabolites there are only
very limited information we have in hand
so when we want to say what's what are
the metabolites that's driving the
differentiation between you know
different tissue types we really have a
hard time so to address that question I
look at my chroma I look at my
chromatogram so this is a UV absorption
from a chromatogram from my analysis so
at the beginning things are more polar
and at the ends things are more non
polar but what I what I've come to
realize is that you can actually divide
this base on their retention time or
based on their relative polarity and we
know that this are physiologically
relevant because we can click into every
single peak in here which represent a
metabolize and look at their UV
absorption profile so we see that the
peaks in this area tend to have
identical or similar UV absorption
profile that's characteristic of
phenolic acid set
similarly Peaks within this area looks
like Ben's oxen whites and pigs within
this area looks like flavonoids and this
is probably not so surprising if you
think about if there are the same class
of compounds which means they're
structurally related to each other then
their polarity should be more or less
similar to each other as well right
so that means we can divide we can
subset our chromatograms into different
groups and then putative lycée are they
different in this retention time range
then we can say oh maybe they're
different mostly because of phenolic
acid and if they're different mostly in
this area of the chromatogram then it's
the flavonoids that's causing the
difference so indeed when we look at
this we can plot the negative log of p
value from our previous two way ANOVA
analysis and what you see is that each
dot here represents a single mass
feature and they're not distributed
uniformly across our chromatograph okay
for example we come here tissue type we
see there are significantly more mass
features that are significantly
different widths in the flavonoid
flavonoid time range whereas when we
look at the mass features that's
differentiated between subpopulations
they're almost exclusively within
depends extended range okay so we can
actually compare the negative log of p
value from two way ANOVA with another
one way ANOVA and then say is there any
significant difference between each
retention time group and the answer is
yes okay what your eyeballing is
actually happening so for tissue type
most of the most of differentiating part
are we seeing a flavonoid time range
whereas for the SubPop genetic sub
population they're mostly differentiated
based on bins ox androids okay so is
that actually happening we can look at
some examples okay so for example if we
compare the lift tip and fleet base and
this is Toto UV absorption profile and
we see that there's clear absence of any
flavonoids in the leaf base so we see
that flavonoids are exclusively found in
the tip of the of the leaf okay so
that's the primary driving factor of
differentiating this to tissue type and
when we look at genetic defined sub
populate
we see that Bendix enjoys such as in
this case dim boa is significantly lower
in tropical lines whereas the same
tropical lines tend to accumulate a
different Bendix annoyed compound called
HTML glucoside okay so we do find out
the same thing looking at specifics as
well as the global analysis so so far
I've been showing you analysis based on
a priori knowledge okay so we know that
the the different samples can be
categorised into either tip or base or
they think can be categorized into
different genetically defined
subpopulations but how about if we just
examine this big data set without any a
priori knowledge I just want to know how
are the mass feature is distributed
across my entire population okay so in
this to plot again I'm analyzing the tip
and base data separately from each other
on the x-axis I'm looking at the
frequency for each mass feature at which
it's being detected so basically this is
a histogram right
whereas on y-axis is how often they are
so we see that those in tip and base we
have a bimodal distribution okay so
there are about 15% of all the mass
features that we detected I found almost
ubiquitously like over 90% of the Matata
genotypes that we examined half this
mass features whereas we also have this
significant L over 40% of the
metabolites are only found in less than
20% of the entire population and I think
this really really highlights the vast
chemical diversity that's existing
within this population and you can think
of this kind of as essential metabolites
there's apparently of liquid sweet and
there's something like expendable
metabolites if you will and we also see
that there's actually a significant
difference in how this to distribution
look like between the two dishes have
tissue types such that in the base you
have more of the expendable metabolites
whereas in the tip distribution is
actually more flat okay so the bimodal
pattern is more up is less obvious
okay so but when I first got this result
my concern was really are this tells
really just noise from a metabolomics
analysis because those are the exact
same pattern what you will expect from
the tab from lcms noise okay they tend
to occur in very small subsets of your
entire population and they're kind of
accounting a big part of your data set
so it'll be it'll kind of suck if you
publishes and find out all these are
actually just noise not true metabolites
so one characteristic associated with
mass spec noise is that they also tend
to have lower intensity because they're
they're just a machine noise they're not
representative of true metabolised
founding samples so what I decided to
test is to see thus the occurrence
frequency somehow correlate with the
intensity off of a mass feature so in
both tip and base we found a very weak
positive correlation so it does seems
like the ones that occur at lower
frequency tend to have lower intensity
as well but you also see that this
distribution is so broad you have mass
features that occur for example almost
less than 20% of the population that
have higher intensity than the ones
that's found in vigorously so we do
think that most of the mass features
that we are finding here are not noise
from the machine but I think you have
already noticed that across this
positive correlation we also have
noticeable exceptions okay so this mass
features here are occurring less than
20% of all our all the genotypes we have
examined but they are found at very high
intensity they're colored based on a 95%
confidence interval of a linear
regression okay so we decided to look at
some of this so what are these mass
features that are rare but occurring at
high intensity so when we look at this
three for example showing one of them
have a mass to charge ratio of 350 3.5
we see that actually you can find an
exact same mass feature exact you can
find exact same master charge rate range
in another
in other genotypes okay so for example
in this genotype call for two to six we
have this to metabolize with that
particular mass to charge ratio however
in CML 45 we have a completely different
different peak showing up that has the
exact same molecular weight but
different retention time and they're
actually occurring a much higher
intensity so that you see the original
two peaks tend to be really short or
really small in this case so that means
we I interpret this as a rear isomer so
they have the exact same molecular
weight but different polarity so
different 2d structure so that they
allude at a different retention time
okay so when we look at all three of
this what's really interesting is that
all three of them show you the exact
have a shared ms/ms
or tendon ms fragment okay so this
metabolize can be fragmented so that you
get the parental ion but also the
franklin ions so you see all three of
this rare high-intensity metabolites
have a shared fragment which means they
are structurally related if you do the
mass between them you have a
hydroxylation and a methylation okay so
that further strengthened our hypothesis
that they are probably structurally
related with each other and if we look
at occurrence of this three metabolites
or three mask features so here I'm
showing a student phylogeny off my 282
population and then on the lower the
color the color plot in blue I'm showing
where that the top ass feature is being
detected at high intensity whereas in
yellow they're not detected and you see
that most of the time there are
co-occurrence which means when you find
one of them all three of them are
probably there okay so this strongly
suggests that this three metabolize
they're rare they're high intensity and
they're structurally related to each
other okay so we really want to now look
for you know what's the genetic basis
why do we sometimes have this rare
isomers why sometimes we have the more
common ways so for that again that's
when we need to do the genome-wide
Association study but before we actually
look at any of this unknown metabolites
we want to make sure that our G was is
actually working so that's when we go
back to our old friend Ben's oxy knows
where we previously used by parental
mapping population of this metabolize
and then correctly identify their
respective biosynthetic genes so we want
to use this as our positive controls for
the jiwa study and say can we recover
the same gene using the same mass
feature or the same metabolites okay and
the answer is yes when we map with
symbol in kuba glucoside we found it's
virus inside between px 13 and we map
with when we map with HTML glucoside not
only do we find the previously
identified biases active gene B X 12 we
also found this significant snip unknown
located towards the end of chromosome 9
so that's really interesting so I got
sidetracked it a little bit so I want to
know what is this unknown why why do I
have another snip here so we know B X 12
is a biosynthetic gene is this another
biosynthetic gene here so that's when I
go to their genome and then look at p73
versus CML 247 genome so CML 247 is a
tropical line remember previously I
mentioned tropical lines tend to have
higher amount of HTM or glucose ID
however when we compare their genome
there doesn't seem to be any structural
variation in terms of presence/absence
okay and that's where our G Y snip has
are located so our clear candidate at
this point will be this gene right here
which encodes a protein phosphatase to
see family protein okay so the way we
look at this is I go back to cow's
expression data and then plot out its
expression across our entire G West
lines and then we take the two tails of
this expression distribution and then
compare their H timba glucoside
metabolites and indeed we see that for
the lines that express this gene a high
level they tend to have significantly
higher aged in Bogalusa side so this
will be strong evidence suggesting that
this expression of this gene at least is
Co segregating with our metabolic
phenotype which means this would be a
very nice candidate genes to say does
that actually regulate HT more glucoside
biosynthesis or metabolism in vivo
okay so that's a good size story from
the positive control how about the rare
isomers were talking about earlier so we
did genetic mapping again so this is
rather preliminary state data at this
point so I've used a slightly different
genetic data set but what we find out is
that this three potentially structurally
related metabolites map to the same
exact locus towards the end of
chromosome four so probably not too
surprising we've seen this before the
structurally related ferrell or sucrose
is mapped to the same locus as well okay
so what is within this locus there so
lucky for us one of the lines the half
this rear isomers again is CML 2:47
which we have the genome so we compared
a genome of 240 cm l/24 t7 with p73 and
what we found is a 40 kb insertion with
specific to the CML 2:47 which contains
four putative gene models one of them
being one of them being a putative and
so sign in Iowa synthesis regulator so
anthocyanins is also in the feel
appropriate pathway so we think that
maybe this is what we're looking for but
at this point I think at least we have
preliminary evidence associated this
associating this 40 kb insertion with
those rare isomers that we observed okay
so so far I've been again looking at
individuals but remember I mentioned
there over 3,900 mass features that we
can map and if you just do that one by
one for a look at that manually for
every one of them you know that take
probably 3900 graduate students to do
that okay so instead I'll compile their
jiwa result and then again on the x-axis
I'm looking at genetic locus for snips
and then I'm counting for each snip or
each genetic locus how many metabolites
G Waze hits that I got and again we
start to see these towers coming up okay
which means small genetic locus
associated with large part of the
metabolomic a so then what are the
metabolites that map to there again it's
always the question about what what are
the metabolites what are the mass
features remember I've already come up
with a putative
into that which is looking at retention
time okay so what we see is that
structurally related metabolites tend to
have clustered retention time okay so
what we can do then is to say if we
measured the variance of retention time
of mass features and mapped the same
locus that give us a measure of how
structurally related are those okay so
that's exactly what I did
so in this plot I'm measuring the log of
variance of retention time you see the
background level up here and you start
to see all this valleys dipping down
which means the mass features are
physically clustered together on the
chromatogram and if we compared this
plot to the G wasps result we have
almost perfect correspondence okay
whenever you have a peak on the number
of G was hits in the genome you also
have a valley in the retention time what
that tells us is that structurally
related metabolites tend to be regulated
by the same locus in your genome when
you say that out loud it makes a lot of
sense but when you want to want your
data to say that to you it takes a
little bit more work so we can actually
try to identify what are the genes or
what are the structural variants there
that's associated we see that in bread
there are for example known Ben's ox
annoyed biosynthetic genes that we can
recover from this analysis and also in
blue there will be the putative found
notes okay okay so in summary what have
I told you today
so I've coaches three stories first we
discovered to metabolize that has not
been reported in maize before cost - I
ate and smoothens I see we think they're
related to Fusarium Bremner and
resistance and we show you that a saline
signaling and probably iron - expression
is positively regulating this
acetylation reaction and then we extend
that from single metabolites - across
the entire metabolome to show you that
correlation between metabolomics and
transcriptomics analysis can help us to
pinpoint candidate genes from
quantitative genetics results and
finally we extended that same approach
to a much more diverse she was and she
was population and show you add a global
scale that's structurally related
tablets tend to be Co regulated by the
same locus in the genome okay so I think
with that being said I think that's all
of my research part I would like to take
a pause here before my long and
emotional acknowledgment section and
everybody forget about your questions so
I would like to take any questions you
may have thank you yes it's a lot to
consider here so when you look at the
sampling the tip which is a well
differentiated terminal differentiated
tissue and the base of the leaf or you
have still you know many cells along
gating some differentiating depending on
you know where the state is statuses
that believed to diversity panel
wouldn't you suspect that there's a lot
of variations still within the base of
the leaf and it could be influencing
some of your results too
I mean like when you look at one of the
major concerns you know when we do a
tree watch we hope to explain the
variance in phenotype by various in
genotype right but then there's no way
you can you can talk about that outside
the framework of development so there
will be differentiation and development
and indeed many of the many of the
genotypic difference we saw or probably
can be attributed to different
biological differences in rate of
development so we try to do that as
consistently as possible as consistently
as possible but you know if we map to an
ox in response factor that that's also
biologically true right so it's
biologically relevant so we're not just
looking at a bio synthetic enzyme in
secondary metabolism pathway per se so
yeah
yeah
so sorry I probably didn't say that very
clearly there so there's three does 353
there are isomers so if we go back sorry
guys I have to mess up somewhere okay so
both dis chromatograms are done with
mass to charge ratio the same master
charge ratios so this two are isomers
okay right because they have the same
molar weight but different retention
times okay but what I'm saying is that
this is only one of this dots up here
there's 369 and the 383 are the other
two I'm not saying this three are
isomers of each other but rather there
are series of rare isomers which we can
find a more common more common
counterparts in other genotype the
second question is 700 do you have an
idea of a related sorry can't say the
first part of your question again I do
features that you got for the
differential now so can you say they are
right so apparently the data is there so
we can use the same kind of retention
time analysis to say you know where are
all those 700 Mass feature allocated in
my chromatograph and that give us some
idea about what they are and my guess
based on the G wasps result is that
there are probably most in mostly in the
stands are so annoyed pathway as well
that would be my guest but I don't know
that yep
classic so you're very beginning of your
slideshow yeah we don't know you know so
so why did you choose this particular
you know range good question so when we
look at this i remember i know towards
the end kind of truce areum just fall
out of the picture so sorry for for the
fungal biologist here but remember we're
trying to look at secondary metabolites
we're trying to look for metabolites was
known that's associated with biochemical
defense so that's why we decided to use
a 50 percent methanol extract where we
get most of the so-called mid polarity
metabolites whereas if you look at
sugars you know or primary metabolites
there that are important for biochemical
defense but traditionally they're not
associated with that and also you can
you can make the argument to say why are
we not looking at lipids you know so so
whenever you're looking at metabolomics
it's never comprehensive per se so the
argument we're making here are limited
to you know really if you look at the
chromatogram we really see primarily
three major classes of compounds we see
phenolic acid you see Bendix a noise
when we see flavonoids I can't tell you
anything about sugars for lipids or
whatever so the question the question is
at the beginning of my slide I make the
argument that biochemical and molecular
markers are less work but this doesn't
look like less work can you can you try
to correlate what we observe here to any
kind of
for example disease symptoms that we can
measure so I think correlation will be a
little bit too ambitious to the chief
but what we can do is to do a pairwise
comparison which you cannot do if user
started out the quantitative genetics
approach by directly scoring symptoms
okay
so right now since we have identified
specific locus that's associated with
metabolites that are probably associated
with resistance then we can say let's
find a mutant in this particular gene
and then we can do pairwise comparison
is there any significant difference
between my mutant versus well type that
we know are only different by this
biochemical phenotype and that's exactly
what I'm planning to do with the
vesicular vesicular transport protein
because in that case I have a very
specific manipulation genetically so I
can say not only cannot test is there
any biochemical difference between my
mutant and wild type is there a
significant difference in their
biological phenotype in terms of disease
resistance unfortunately we cannot do
that for the feral or sucrose part
because it's on cue if you knock how
high onto or if you disturb a saline
pathway yeah you will see a phenotype
that that that you can say that's
because the feral or sucrose because
there are two thousand other things
that's also changed in people of the of
the Pharos sucrose you mean I'm sorry
the Smigiel science - idea what kind of
mechanism yeah yeah so there
I would say two classes of mechanisms
that's been associated with resistance
so the first class for example phenolic
acids it's been shown data has in vivo
in vitro activity so it means that
somehow it's biocidal or inhibits the
gross okay so molecular molecular
mechanism we don't really know
so there are antioxidants so antioxidant
are thought to be good but you know we
don't really know but on the other hand
probably something more relevant is that
usually phenolic acids are associated
with structural structural
fortifications the word I'm looking for
okay so vast majority of the phenolic
acid you found in planta are actually
esterified to the cell wall so it's been
shown that one of the major response one
of the first response to fungal
infection is that you have this major
production induction of phenolic acid
and they tend to all go towards cell
wall and reinforce our cell wall so if
the two compounds that we found actually
play a role by reinforcing the cell wall
then we would not have captured that
activity with the in vitro inhibition
assay I hope that answered a question
that approaches biased words finding
it's a good question I can't exact same
questions before so my idea is that now
that we are I think we are in the era
where data generation it's always going
to outpace data analysis you can kind of
you can do this kind of global analysis
but then when you try to dive into
specifics you have to go in with
hypotheses so you can say okay now I
associate this metabolite with some kind
of biological phenotype that I'm
interested in then I can go in to say
you know what are the genes what are my
G wats result and what I found what
what I believe will be valuable from
this analysis is not necessarily you
know the final correspondence between
structural related relatedness and a
particular genome but genetic locus but
rather in the future if you have a
candidate compound that you're
interested in and then you can go to
this data set the gos result is right
there and you can just go and say what
is my candidate gene and basically you
reduce entire PhD ceases to experiment
right with the with the you know
maturation of of CRISPR and other genome
editing technology you can say okay I
hear I have a very clear Candida gene if
I've altered that does that do I have a
chemical phenotype do I have a
biological phenotype and I think that's
the way this resource can be used in the
future I haven't thought about that too
much so we know that from from us oh so
you can transform this fungus with GFP
and then do fungus tracking we know that
initially grows intracellularly
and then that and then during the
intercellular face it produced mycotoxin
and kills the plant cell and then move
into a more intracellular necro trophic
phase so for or so first for all the
metabolomic QTL analysis we did a
constitutively there's no fungus
induction whatsoever and for all the
earlier induction experiment that I did
there are six days post inoculation so
there barely start transitioning into
the intracellular face so I'm not
exactly sure you know how much Pollak
Lee the plant will switch between fast
as the fungus switch from an
intercellular to an intro intracellular
life stop but I think there's been a lot
of transcriptomics analysis done on that
front so that's probably a good way to
look at it okay so my advisor is just
reminding me I also have an
acknowledgement to do and he also want
to have lunch so let's do that so so one
thing that I'm not sure I have the
luxury to do anymore now that I'm doing
it on a Friday time slot is that you
have a very very long acknowledgement to
to recognize everybody in my family and
apparently you know I wouldn't be the
person I am without all their help and
their company but so I try to restrict
my acknowledgement to all the people
I've met here in Cornell so I want to
recognize all my collaborators here
without whose work none of this would be
possible so throughout the talk I hope
you recognize that this is a really
diverse project we use many many
different approaches and I'm no
expertise in any of those so the only
expertise I have is to find the right
person and do the right experiment for
me okay so I really want to thank
everybody here that helped me throughout
the entire project so I
over-over my time here I'm also being
extensively working with students both
undergraduate and summer interns they
make my life so much more fun and my
wife and I can go to cruise tour when
they take pictures of fruit so that's
pretty good and also I want to recognize
all my lab mates throughout this times
it's been obviously being evolving over
time and I really want to thank them for
all the inspiration all the ideas I got
from them as well as there are patients
to listen to all my brain dump also I
want to recognize my committee members
Rebecca Nelson and Gary Bergstrom who
both have been really inspirational very
supportive and very resourceful and I
think again this project wouldn't have
been done without any of their help and
of course finally I want to recognize
the advisor okay and in the gender lab
is kind of a tradition that at the edge
or access seminar you want to give kind
of a famous philosophical quote directly
actual quote from George so in the past
his bicycling habit has been the subject
of discussion so here I want to you I
want to take this quote right here okay
so this happened when
visiting an alpaca farm in in true
Leesburg and they also have pigs here so
that's what George said to me so I so
the context I think it's pigs and George
said it's a great they treat you equally
as one of themselves and I think that's
also the same kind of philosophy that
George has been using to treat his
graduate students that he treats his
graduates equally asked one of himself
so but I do realize I need to give a
little bit more context next time I
present in conference and say that or to
present a Georgia treat his grad
students like pigs come alright and last
but not least I want to recognize
everybody here who take the time to come
I really want to say you know the my
time here in Cornell would not be the
same without any of you so you mean we
may not be collaborated directly on my
thesis project I probably met you in the
class we probably work together as
teaching staff and we probably were
students together in the class and all
those interactions really gave me idea
and I really own a big time to all of
you guys and really from this project I
think one of the message I got is at
this time where the merit of diversity
has often been questioned and sometimes
been attacked I can reflect on my own
experience in Cornell and stay convinced
that if life itself is an emergent
property then our society and our
science should also be greater than some
of its parts thank you this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu